hi i'm mark rosati culinary director of
shake shack and today we're making our
shack burger i always open the bun
gently making sure the bottom and top
are still attached with that hinge
what's great about that hinge is when
you shut the burger and bite into it all
the juices will start to come out of the
back and all that flavor stays with
inside the bun i love toasting potato
buns because it gives you great contrast
between the pillowy soft outside the bun
i started out shake shack about 10 years
ago when there was just one location in
new york city in a park with no
aspirations to grow we're now at over
130 locations worldwide and the one
thing we've realized as we continue to
grow if you do really good high quality
comfort food do it fresh these things
are universal everywhere our sauce has
become quite iconic amongst our fans the
shack sauce recipe in our new cookbook
we wanted to make it more simplistic
than the actual recipe we use at shake
shack the recipe at shake shack has so
many more ingredients it's very labor
intensive we want to give you a shortcut
that's going to get you very close shake
shack is a modern day version of the
great classic american roadside burger
stand and we were big fans
of the style of taking patties and
smashing them into the griddles it's
something we've always admired because
it creates this wonderful crispy salty
crust when it comes time to flip the top
of the patty you'll start to see these
little grooves develop with the juices
bubbling through also you'll start to
see little brown bits caramelize around
the perimeter i was a fan of shake shack
before i ever worked there and when i
first got in line and actually got the
shack burger myself i remember taking
out the bag looking at going i can't
believe i just waited an hour and a half
to two hours for this
it was so deceptively simple but what i
loved about it i found very inspiring
was there wasn't any crazy wild
mushrooms on top or little pieces of
foie gras and caramelized onions it was
a good simple old-fashioned hamburger
not too dissimilar to i think a lot of
people grew up eating and i was a fan i
actually went to the shake shack for a
interview and to be honest i did not
want to take that job i wanted to keep
going to find dining route because i
kept thinking about a teacher i had in
high school who said if you don't buckle
down and study you're gonna wind up
flipping hamburgers like that was a bad
thing when i went to see them pull the
burger meat out of the refrigerator to
cook it i realized the same thoughtful
approach to cooking was very much alive
in this little shack i didn't know you
could take this level of thought to
cooking a hamburger
oh yes
[Music]
you